well there is there is no doubt that the
whole discussion globally about how to
deal with the climate crisis is still
for most people the most essential part
and it's it would be very unfortunate
unless we find ways to deal seriously
with the climate crisis and to prevent
it because that we unless that happens
we certainly are not going to see
sustainable development as we look ahead
I think basically when you look at all
the elements that are on the table and
in the discussion even linked up to the
climate change discussion all the key
issues linked to the sustainable
development concept itself are part of
that discussion so it's not as if
something has been completely lost as we
focus on climate because in the whole
area of adaptation of all the sectors
that need to be involved to deal with
reducing the impact upon our climate we
touch most issues which are relevant in
a sustainable development context
well I think whether you look at the the
question of the way our democracies most
countries are today democracies although
not all democracy means public
participation and it means at the same
time elected representatives and
democratic institutions that can help
safeguard the way that people live
together and the way we live in
relationship with the surrounding world
and our environment so whether you look
at it at national level or at the global
level there is this direct link between
public participation and engagement and
the way that leaders who have been
elected or who are at lees in any case
responsible for the future of their
people how they can act together and
have addition and a method of moving
ahead in a consist